[Musik]
heute live ganz herzlich willkommen und
einen schönen guten abend die welt
blickt nach glasgow zum weltklimagipfel
und das tun auch wir der britische
premier boris johnson der sprach bei
seiner eröffnungsrede davon dass die
bombe des klimawandels entschärft werden
müsse und das ist eine minute vor 12 sei
es sei wie in einem james bond film nur
dass es in diesem fall nicht um fiktion
sondern eben um fakten gehe
für den einen mehr oder für den aachener
offenbar weniger interessant james bond
gut und schön aber wie soll die bombe
des klimawandels entschärft werden
wandel das passieren wie schnell und wer
soll am ende die rechnung dafür bezahlen
mit diesen und anderen fragen wollen uns
heute beschäftigen und wir freuen uns
später dann über zwei äußerst kompetente
gesprächspartnerin wir sprechen mit
luisa neubauer wohl die bekannteste
vertreterin der klimaaktivisten von
friedrichs verfügt und wir sprechen mit
professor karen pittel klima ökonomen am
münchner ifo-institut und auch jederzeit
natürlich wie immer herzlich eingeladen
mitzumachen fragen zu stellen und zu
kommentieren und ihr seht es schon in
meinem hintergrund mein kollege und
umweltexperte das zdf volker anders er
ist für uns vor ort in glasgow und mit
ihm wenn wir jetzt direkt schalten und
volker ja ich habe gerade die aussagen
von boris johnson erwähnt hat man denn
den eindruck dass inzwischen wirklich
jeder nation und jedem der führenden
köpfe dort der ernst der lage bewusst
ist
naja hier auf der konferenz glaube ich
würde es niemanden geben der zugibt dass
er so wie anders sieht das der
klimawandel doch nicht von menschen
beeinflusst ist würde ja niemand zugeben
ich denke schon dass die allermeisten
verstanden haben worum es geht einige
vielleicht dann doch noch nicht so wenn
ich an brasilien szenario denke der ja
nach wie vor der ansicht ist dass ist
alles um die natur und das geht alles
von selber und niemand müsse sich
kümmern solche ausnahmen gibt es immer
aber jetzt ist die ganz große mehrheit
der hier der guten sehr gut 190 länder
die hier vertreten sind sind wirklich on
the track wie so schön heiß sind also
dabei und haben verstanden worum es geht
und guckt ja auch manche dann immer ganz
besonders wir sprechen nachher noch über
die bundeskanzlerin aber auch der us
präsident joe biden hat sich heute
geäußert welche signale zum beispiel
senden die usa
[Musik]
also das aller wichtigste signal ist
nicht neu das hat beiden gleich am
ersten tag seines amtsantritts ja gesagt
er ist den pariser klimaabkommen wieder
beigetreten das ist ganz ganz wichtig
denn unter trump waren die usa
ausgetreten und dann hätte ja ein ganz
großer co2 emittent gefehlt die usa
wären nicht mehr in der verpflichtung
des pariser abkommens gewesen jetzt sind
sie es wieder und in diesem zuge hat
beiden heute angekündigt dass auch die
usa im land sehr sehr viel für den
klimaschutz tun werden sie es wird um
ganz viel milliarden gehen die
investiert werden genau das gesagt hat
er freilich nicht auch das ist hier so
der diplomatische stil dass man solche
ankündigung gerne macht aber interessant
ist dass beiden das verknüpft hat mit
interessanten wirtschaftlichen
perspektiven also wenn man jetzt in eine
grüne wirtschaft investiere dann würden
das tolle jobs bedeuten ist würde neu
ist neue perspektiven auch für die
familien bedeuten und nicht nur
gelegenheitsjobs sondern jobs auf dauer
das ist so der american style wie man
klimaschutz dann verkaufen möchte die
wirtschaft kommt in schwung alle haben
etwas davon und natürlich profitiert am
ende das klima und damit auch die
gesamte menschheit so die theorie von
joe biden ob das so kommt noch muss er
durch den kongress um die ganzen
milliarden dann auch locker zu machen ob
das alles gelegen wird das wenn wir ein
paar wochen später dann sehen in der tat
hatte auch noch hürde vor sich immerhin
er ist vor ort und er spricht eben
offenbar auch mit einigem optimismus
nicht alle staatschefs sind da jean ping
aus china und auch der russische
präsident wladimir putin die fehlen wie
wird das vor ort bewertet
das wird natürlich als absolut fatale
bewertet gerade china mit knapp 30
prozent ja der weltweit größte emittent
von treibhausgasen
ist nicht da also das ist schon wie soll
man sagen eine art absage unter dem
motto ihr könnt das alles ohne mich ohne
china machen allerdings auch das ist
nicht wirklich neu denn china hat schon
2015 auf der klimakonferenz in paris wo
das klimaabkommen jahr verabschiedet
worden ist gesagt ja wir machen da zwar
mit aber erst ab 20.30 werden wir
anfangen aktiv in den klimaschutz
einzusteigen um zum beispiel die
energie-versorgung chinas weg von kohle
hin zu erneuerbaren energien zu bringen
insofern ja dass ich vielleicht gedacht
habe ich noch ich schon gesagt 2030 geht
es los warum soll ich da jetzt nach
glasgow fahren ich habe nichts neues
anzubieten habe auch keine lust mich
hier von allen anderen beschimpfen zu
lassen dann lassen wir das und was
russland dann geht vielleicht ich mir
putin der hat ein ganz anderes problem
denn nämlich ungefähr 50 prozent des
gesamten exportvolumens
russland 50 prozent das sind die
fossilen energieträger gas kohle öl
davon lebt russland wenn russland jetzt
klimaschutz machen würde das würde
bedeuten dass diese 50 prozent einnahmen
aus dem exportgeschäft wegfallen würden
also ehrlich gesagt das doch völlig klar
dass so jemand keine lust hat hier
irgendwelche angaben zum klimaschutz zu
machen und da irgendwelche
versprechungen abzugeben
das wird so nicht funktionieren
russland poker da sehr hoch und na ja
wir haben ja in deutschland die debatte
mit dem russischen gas und gerade wird
alles teurer das wird ein wie soll man
sagen eine schöne aufgabe für die neue
bundesregierung nicht nix dann auch sein
noch ist die alte bundeskanzlerin
sozusagen die geschäftsführende
bundeskanzlerin frau merkel vor ort und
auch sie hat heute nochmal töne
angeschlagen die sich ja doch ein
bisschen von dem abheben was man sonst
so auf diesen konferenzen von ihr
gewohnt waren wie hast du das
wahrgenommen
naja nun hat sie zunächst mal auf der
weltbühne bühne das wichtigste deutsche
klimaschutzziel öffentlich benannt
nämlich klimaneutral soll deutschland
seien im jahre 2045 also klimaneutral
heißt dass nur so viel treibhausgase
ausgestoßen werden wie in der natur
wieder gebunden werden können das mag
für einige in der welt noch neu gewesen
sein und damit ist deutschland ja eines
der länder die am frühesten die
klimaneutralität erreichen wollen das
ist heute sozusagen hier zu protokoll
genommen worden und ein zweites war
interessant hat uns auch joe biden
gesagt dass angela merkel setzt sehr auf
die bilaterale zusammenarbeit also auf
die zusammenarbeit zwischen zwei drei
oder vier ländern um gemeinsam den
besten weg zum klimaschutz zu finden
unter dem motto wenn ich ne milliarde
für den klimaschutz habe wo muss ich die
investieren damit am meisten klimaschutz
rauskommt und ein projekt was ihr
benannt worden ist es ein gemeinsames
projekt usa großbritannien deutschland
in südafrika um südafrika raus aus der
kohle zu bringen das ist auch ein dickes
rat was man da drehen muss der in
südafrika hat 90 prozent kohle strom im
netz wenn das gelingt da den einstieg in
den ausstieg zu finden wäre das
wunderbar naja auf der anderen seite
waren wir ziemlich rum mit unserem
eigenen kohleausstieg passt nicht so
ganz zusammen aber egal hauptsache
solche bilateralen kooperationen kommen
zustande und vielleicht macht das ja
auch schule dieses vorbild dann werden
wir vielleicht in zwei wochen einfach
noch ein paar dieser kooperation hier
erleben dass wir das wäre schon mal ein
gutes ergebnis ja wo wir gerade von
angela merkel sprechen sie hat ja nun
schon einige dieser konferenzen
mitgemacht und das wird jetzt nun die
letzte sein hat man den eindruck dass
sie deswegen anders agiert hat sie jetzt
vielleicht irgendwie auch eine gewisse
lockerheit in dem wissen na ja gut also
hinter mir müssen es dann die anderen
richten nach mir
das habe ich jetzt nicht festgestellt
angela merkel ist die meisterin der
internationalen diplomatie und da ist
auch viel auszubalancieren
ich muss ist noch mal vielleicht sagen
wenn hier 190 länder am start sind und
jedes land hat natürlich eigene
interessen wirtschaftliche interessen
viele entwicklungsländer leiden extrem
unter den klimawandel und das muss
ausbalanciert werden so ist eine
un-konferenz eben angelegt und angela
merkel wie gesagt hat das schon immer
meisterhaft verstanden und das wenigste
davon passiert in der öffentlichkeit der
hinter verschlossenen türen da werden
dann gespräche geführt da geht es dann
auch um gelder die vielleicht hier und
da noch gezahlt werden und bestimmte
dinge hinzubekommen das ist naja im
hintergrund hat die klimadiplomatie ich
glaube nicht dass sie sich heute sehr
anders verhalten hat als die auf den
anderen bisherigen klimakonferenzen war
auch nicht unser eindruck aber man
könnte ja mal auf die idee kommen aber
ich glaube dafür ist sie dann natürlich
auch zu sehr kanzlerin und auch profi
genug du hast angesprochen die
schwierigkeiten die bestehen so viele
parteien unter einen hut zu bekommen und
auch dieses einstimmigkeitsprinzip was
er dann auch gilt am ende das ist alles
nicht leicht bei dem versuch dann am
ende auch wirklich zählbares dann
zustande zu bringen wann wäre denn der
klimagipfel aus deiner sicht schon ein
erfolg
also es ist ja einfach so dass diese
konferenz den auftrag hat das abkommen
das in paris 2015 geschlossen worden ist
die einfache in die umsetzung zu bringen
und dieses abkommen besteht aus etlichen
paragrafen und artikeln und die werden
hier in den vielen arbeitsgruppen nach
und nach angegangen und zu ende
diskutiert und hoffentlich dann auch
verabschiedet also zum beispiel geht es
um den artikel 6 dass da hatten sie geht
es um die internationale zusammenarbeit
da stellt sich die frage wenn zwei
länder zusammenarbeit mache einfach mal
ein beispiel an ta baut einen windkraft
ein wind tag windkraftpark inland b
stellt sich die frage in welchem land
wird dann eigentlich die co2 ersparnis
angerechnet in dem land wo der windpark
steht oder in dem land das es bezahlt
hat das sind so
etwas vereinfacht ausgedrückt die
knackpunkte und die es hier geht ein
anderer man mag es kaum glauben der
steckt drin in dem so genannten regeln
nach dem pariser abkommen das regelwerk
da steckt dahinter dass man endlich mal
gemeinsame statistische verfahren
entwickeln muss nachdem dann klimadaten
erhoben werden das ist so leicht
dahergesagt aber in vielen ländern
gerade in entwicklungsländern gibt es
eben kein statistisches bundesamt wo man
anrufen kann unter dem motto hey was
haben wir eigentlich gerade für den co2
ausstoß viele länder wissen das gar
nicht und wenn sie es wissen wissen sie
auch nicht wie sie die daten zusammen
bekommen können und dann muss es noch
international nach den gleichen methoden
funktionieren wie sonst will man in den
verhandlungen denn eigentlich über co2
ersparnis reduktion reden wenn man gar
nicht genau weiss nach welcher methode
die zahlen zustande gekommen sind das
wäre dann völlig unvergleichbar
funktioniert nicht auch das wird
verhandelt und der dritte knackpunkt wo
ich ein paar signale gehört habe dass es
gelingen könnte sind eben die gelder für
die entwicklungsländer zusammen zu
bekommen sowohl für maßnahmen zur
anpassung an klima schäden als auch zur
zum klimaschutz direkt da geht es um 20
milliarden us-dollar die mindestens
mindestens jetzt noch hier auf den tisch
gelegt werden müssen das hätte schon
2020 der fall sein sollen ist bisher
nicht gelungen das glaube ich ist ganz
ganz wichtig wenn das nicht passiert da
werden die entwicklungsländer
möglicherweise das vertrauen in diesen
un prozess verlieren und das wäre ein
gewaltiger rückschlag also das wären so
meine drei benchmarks nach denen ich
gucken werde hier in den nächsten zwei
wochen und wenn wir mal sehen ob etwas
davon dann tatsächlich umgesetzt werden
kann ja gut dass wir da so ein genaues
auge darauf haben wir warten immer noch
auf luisa neubauer wir haben da gerade
noch ein kleines technisches problem sie
kommt wohl noch nicht in die halle aber
wird ja ich höre gerade durch die lässt
sich nicht rein offenbar ist nicht
überall gleich automatisch bekannt
beziehungsweise hat dann sofortigen
eintritt aber wir versuchen das problem
zu lösen wir sprechen aber sehr gerne
noch ein bisschen mit dir volker wir
haben ja auch immer user fragen die ich
jetzt gerne einfach mit einbeziehen
möchte die bands schreibt uns über
youtube wenn wir von der co2 steuer
sprechen für zukünftige emissionen wäre
es nicht gerechter global gesehen auch
für die bisher verursachten emissionen
aus der vergangenheit aufzukommen also
so eine art kompensation wird das
diskutiert
nein das wird nicht diskutiert es wird
in der tat keine co2 steuer aber ein co2
preis diskutiert und diese systeme die
gibt es auch schon aber deutschland hat
jetzt gerade angefangen anfang diesen
jahres es gibt vergleichbare systeme in
einigen bundesstaaten der usa es gibt
sogar 1 in china was im aufbau begriffen
ist und viele sagen das hat übrigens
angela merkel in ihrer rede heute auch
noch mal bestätigt die ist ein großer
fan von vom co2 preis weil wenn fossile
energieträger einfach teurer werden dann
wird sich jeder überlegen ob ich das
geld und ob also die cd co2 preis
bezahlen möchte oder lieber dann doch in
regenerative energien umsteigen das
fängt an bei der heizung daheim geht
weiter zu elektromobilität aber ganz
wichtig ist es natürlich für die
industrie die hohen energieeinsatz hat
also aluminiumindustrie zum beispiel
stahlindustrie und da soll der co2 preis
dazu führen dass eben die feuerung von
beim stahl kochen von kokskohle weg
kommt eben zu grünen so genannten grünen
wasserstoff das ist die idee dabei und
insofern glaube ich dass es ganz gut
funktionieren könnte wichtig wäre
natürlich wenn es ein weltweit
einheitliches system gäbe das gibt es
aber leider noch nicht
volker angres unserer umwelt ekstase
angekommen wenn ich alles sagen da das
ist eine wesentliche informationen sind
sehr dankbar genau wir haben aber genau
noch ein paar minuten beziehungsweise ja
gute minute vielleicht zeit denn wir
wollen uns vorher noch einen bericht
anhören derzeit kann sich dann luisa
entsprechend vorbereiten vielen dank
volker schon mal an dich an dieser
stelle dass du uns so kenntnisreich
durch diese frage schon einmal geführt
hast beziehungsweise uns die antworten
dazu gegeben hast und wir wollen uns
sozusagen als grundlage für den gipfel
in glasgow über den wir ja gleich auch
noch weiter sprechen werden noch einmal
das pariser klima abkommen von 2005 sind
etwas genauer anschauen und vor dem
gespräch mit luisa neubauer und mit
professor karen pittel noch mal kurz
zeigen was ist mit diesem abkommen das
vor sechs jahren geschlossen wurde genau
auf sich hat
2015 haben fast alle staaten der welt in
paris einen vertrag zum schutz des
klimas beschlossen das ziel den
temperaturanstieg auf der erde im
durchschnitt auf deutlich unter zwei
grad im vergleich zur vorindustriellen
zeit zu begrenzen möglichst bei 15 grad
celsius im durchschnitt sind die
temperaturen jetzt schon um über ein
grad gestiegen an vielen orten liegt der
anstieg sogar deutlich darüber zum
beispiel in der nordpolarregion
dort hat sich die eisdecke durch die
milderen winter um fast die hälfte
reduziert das pariser abkommen sieht vor
die hauptverursacher in die
verantwortung zu nehmen mit geld
jährlich sind 100 milliarden us dollar
bis 2025 angepeilt die allerdings längst
nicht beisammen sind und auch mit
konkreter hilfe dort wo der klimawandel
schon spürbar ist die aktuelle prognose
des weltklimarates bezieht sich auf
unterschiedlich starke anstrengungen der
vertragsstaaten und berechnet danach die
temperatur entwicklungen es wird
deutlich mit den aktuellen plänen
treibhausgase einzusparen ist das ziel
nicht erreichbar
deshalb gibt das pariser klimaabkommen
auch vor die länder sollen regelmäßig
nach justieren ihre pläne immer weiter
verbessern und dann strikt einhalten
genau das soll jetzt in glasgow
passieren
passieren und wir sehen schon professor
karen bitte ganz herzlichen dank dass
sie bei uns sind und einen schönen guten
abend soll ich sagen an dieser stelle
ich muss immer mit einem ohren auch so
ein bisschen hinhören was bei uns in
glasgow passiert hatten vielleicht viel
mitbekommen luisa erneuerbare unser
anderer gesprächspartnerin hatte leichte
schwierigkeiten beim betreten der halle
da haben wir gleich noch fragen was da
genau los war aber wir haben jetzt
gerade ja schon den beitrag gesehen zur
pariser
klimakonferenz frau titel erfreulich
einfach mal mit ihnen an da ging es
nicht zuletzt um geld 100 milliarden pro
jahr sind angestrebt die die
hauptverursacher des klimawandels an die
hauptleidtragenden zahlen sollen das
geld kommt aber nicht zusammen oder nur
schleppend woran liegt das ihrer meinung
nach
ist in der bereitstellung der
öffentlichen gelder aber eben auch
vielleicht auch eine unterschätzung
dessen oder überschätzung dessen was man
an privaten geldern zusammen bekommen
wollte diese 100 milliarden sind ja
nicht notwendigerweise alles gelder von
staaten als geschenk an andere staaten
sondern da sind eben auch zum beispiel
verbilligte kredite dabei da sind aber
auch aus dem privatsektor
investitionen dabei und
gerade eben auch die öffentlichen
öffentliche hand hat sich da teilweise
sehr schwer getan die eu hat zum
beispiel gerade angekündigt
beziehungsweise deutschland ihre beitrag
auch zu erhöhen
und da ist noch einiges was man
eigentlich machen könnte also der
beitrag zumindest wieder lange zeit war
der eu waren wenn mich nicht alles
täuscht ungefähr zehn euro pro einwohner
pro jahr und das ist natürlich jetzt
nicht wahnsinnig viel wenn man das auf
den rest der welt um legen wir also
jetzt nur für europa das heißt also hier
sind durchaus noch raum nach oben drin
bist du raus ja da ist noch luft nach
oben das wird mit sicherheit auch luisa
neubauer so sehen ich versuche gerade
noch mal die leitung zu ihr aufzurufen
und da sehe ich sie auch hallo frau
neubauer schön dass sie bei uns sind von
freitag verfügt stellt natürlich ich
glaube die meisten unserer userinnen und
user erkennen sie was war los gab es ein
problem mit dem einlass
ja es ist eine wilde veranstaltung gehe
auf jeden fall und
teilweise chaotischen deswegen kann man
hier nicht einfach so von a nach b
laufen sondern man wird ewig
kontrolliert das ist teilweise sehr
sinnvoll aber teilweise eben auch ja
sehr unübersichtlich so gerne exklusiver
klub offenbar in denen nicht jeder
reifen aber sie haben es jetzt geschafft
gott sei dank wir wollen vielleicht
gerade noch mal frau das ende des
beitrags aufgreifen den wir gerade
gesehen haben also die staaten sollen
ihre pläne regelmäßig nachjustieren
verbessern und vor allem dann auch
einhalten so hatte stories ihnen mit auf
den weg gegeben was meinen sie wie sehr
gelingt den staaten das eigentlich
na ja das glaube ich geht hier gar nicht
so sehr darum was ich meine sondern wir
gucken man muss sie zahlen an stellen
fest das funktioniert nicht wir bewegen
uns auf eine erhitzung von 27 grad zu
das ist nicht irgendwie dummer zufall
oder so aus versehen sondern es eine
politische entscheidung die dahinter
steckt oder vor allem viele politische
entscheidungen
bisher stellen wir fest dass regierung
wahnsinnig gut darin sind sich grün zu
vermarkten und überhaupt kein interesse
daran zeigen dass du noch ehrlich
einzuhalten was sich hier so glorreich
versprechen
ja frau professor mittel wenn sie da
vielleicht gerade entgegnen wollen also
es geht um die 15 grad auf die eben die
erwärmung nach möglichkeit begrenzt
werden soll ist dieses ziel aus ihrer
sicht noch realistisch a und b ist auch
diese zahl sozusagen das alleinige
kriterium auf das man schauen sollte
er wie 1,5 grad sind im pariser abkommen
ist ja auch als zugeständnis an die
kleinen inselstaaten reingekommen aber
spätestens nach dem bericht des
eigentlich sie also das
intergovernmental
panel of climate for climate change sich
auch schon etwas
ist glaube ich schon allen auch bewusst
dass 1,5 grad schon ganze menge sich
schäden nach sich zieht das war nicht
eben von vornherein klar die frage ist
nur können wir das erreichen können wir
es nicht erreichen und moment sind wir
nicht auf projekt orient wo wir das
irgendwie erreichen können das haben
sich zwar mehr als 100 staaten dazu
bekannt dass sie um 2050 herum
klimaneutral werden wollen aber da gebe
ich frau neubauer absolut recht wir
sehen die maßnahme noch nicht im moment
geht es immer mehr nach oben mit den
zielen aber wir sehen nicht die
konkreten maßnahmen die das nachher dann
tatsächlich auch
liefern sollen ja frau neubauer wenn es
um konkrete maßnahmen geht da hat freude
ist für future mit sicherheit einiges im
köcher wofür würden sie sich aussprechen
auch da geht es ja nicht worauf hier
gerade lust habe es ja nicht nachmittags
zusammen und schreiben witzige to listen
für irgendwelche regierungen auf sondern
auch da sagen wir lassen das 1
und hier wirklich jetzt zusagen nicht
wahnsinnig aufwendig rauszufinden was
dringend gemacht werden muss die
bundesregierung jede andere regierung
die hätten die besten beraterinnen
berater zur hand um sich zu informieren
wenn sie denn wollten wir wissen dass
wir im endeffekt von einem ganz
schnellen ausstieg aus kohle öl und gas
sprechen ein ende der kohle und gas
subvention ein ende der kohle öl und gas
expansion wir sprechen von einem großen
umbau der landwirtschaft von
mobilitätssektor industrie und gebäude
sagt ihren also das sind dinge die
mittlerweile ja relativ viele menschen
noch irgendwie ein bisschen im
hinterkopf haben dass es an sich nicht
rock it seit weil es aber natürlich
braucht ist eine bereitschaft der
regierung dann dass er sich auch
loszulegen und tiefe veränderungen
einzugehen wohl wissen dass die
alternative dazu eben klimakatastrophe
ohne ende ist ja dazu passend auch die
frage von unserem user matthias borner
man an sie frau neubauer muss allgemein
das konsumverhalten jedes einzelnen
bürgers der westlichen industrienationen
abnehmen um die ziele zu erreichen also
ist eine verhaltens veränderung
unsererseits erforderlich
die
gibt es braucht es natürlich erst
brauchen fall in erinnerung sei ins
regierung zum beispiel wäre eine
verhaltensänderung in richtung wir
halten unsere eigene internationalen
zusagen ein super eine
verhaltensänderung von
finanziert institution transparent zu
berichten eine verhaltensänderung von
lobbys sich ehrlich darüber zu machen
was sie alles nach plan und wen sie
bestechen dass ich meine natürlich reden
wir auf der ganzen bandbreite von
verhaltensänderungen und wir werden auch
in einer art und weise gewohnheiten
veränderungen erfahren wenn es um
unseren alltag geht aber auch dazu sagen
dass uns einmal auf die prioritäten
kunden ich meine wir reden davon dass
wir entweder jetzt unser verhalten
gesammelt ändern und klimakatastrophen
vermeiden oder eben die klimakatastrophe
kommt und ohnehin alles verändert also
veränderung kommt so oder so
verhaltensänderungen kommt so oder so
die frage ist eben nur kommt sie auf
einer positiven lebensbejahenden
gerechte art und weise wie es selbst
machen oder kommt sie durch krisen die
sich überschlagen das ist ja wo wir
heute sind die haben wir nicht mehr die
wahl zu sagen wir machen überhaupt
nichts und alles bleibt so wie es ist
oder wir machen eben ein bisschen
klimaschutz den der zug ist abgefahren
wenn es denn jemals gab frau professor
titel wie sehen sie das
also dass grundsätzlich bekannt ist was
wir machen müssten dann stimme ich
absolut zu ich sehe nur eben auch das
ist manchmal nicht ganz so einfach ist
also das im prinzip sich die regierung
eine regierung gesagt wir machen das und
das und das und das dann läuft natürlich
immer die gefahr dass die bevölkerung
nicht mitgenommen wird und obwohl
natürlich eine unheimlich hohe
anteil der bevölkerung smart für
klimaschutz ist stellt man eben auch
immer wieder fest auch in
analysen dass die tatsächliche
zahlungsbereitschaft wenn es dann dazu
kommt tatsächlich muss beitragen relativ
gering ist das heißt hier muss man einen
weg finden die belastung so zu verteilen
dass sie als gerecht empfunden wird denn
gerade das ich muss zahlen aber warum
muss ständig zahlen das ist ein ganz
entscheidendes argument und dann ist
natürlich gleichzeitig noch wenn man
sich jetzt aus bundes- regierungssicht
aus eu-sicht das anschaut immer noch die
frage was machen die anderen also wenn
man quasi ganz alleine voranpreschen hat
man vor aber eben auch viele nachteile
von neubauer glaube scharrt mit den
hufen sie möchte gerne
anhalten dürfte also ja natürlich
wenn man den menschen erzählt sozusagen
die klimakrise ist dann wenn alle leute
mehr zahlen müssen dann hat natürlich
niemand lust auf klimaschutz ist dass
man alle märz an müssen hat ihr niemand
lust darauf aber auch da fängt das ja
mit einer ehrlichen kommunikation an
wenn man die menschen so fragen würde
haye habt ihr bock auf einer
eskalierenden nie dagewesene katastrophe
die euch alles nimmt und ihr hab und gut
in frage gestellt die den wunsch
wohlstand für den liga titel gearbeitet
hat da würde keine regierung eine
mehrheit finden aber genau darauf
steuern die regierung ja gerade hin also
letztendlich geht es ja darum dass wir
einmal sozusagen die perspektive richtig
drehen und klar dass darüber sprechen wo
sind wir gerade was ist der ist zustand
wo wurden wir rein manövriert von
regierungen die 40 jahre lang nicht
wirklich gehandelt haben und was sind
die perspektiven die geschaffen werden
können wenn man jetzt loslegt wenn man
aber den ganzen krisen anteil verdeckt
und den menschen ein märchen vorspielt
von einer welt und der ist die
klimakatastrophe eigentlich nur in
lehrbüchern und weise feature dem es
gibt natürlich hat er niemand lust zu
sagen ja lösen so ein bisschen mehr
klimaschutz machen das ist super und
auch zusätzlich glaube ich wäre es
wichtig mal darüber zu sprechen was
heißt denn eigentlich klimaschutz und
wie teuer ist dann eigentlich das
nichthandeln denn gerade zahlen alle
menschen steuerzahler scheint überall
ungefragt unfreiwillig für
klimazerstörung und für klimaschäden und
wenn man das gegenrechnet gegen das was
jetzt notwendig ist um klimaschutz
umzusetzen dann zu sagen stellt sich
auch die kostenfrage nicht mehr so sehr
gefährlich zu werden frau heisig können
gleich weiterreden an der stelle
vielleicht noch mal auch die meinung von
kirsten tempest wer bezahlt das alles
umstieg ja aber wer bezahlt meine neue
heizung und den rest wenn meine rente
oder das einkommen dafür nicht reicht
jeder spricht über die armen hat vier
menschen sind sie ja auch aber was ist
mit den anderen ärmeren menschen die
aktuell nicht viel einkommen haben ist
da ihre antwort na ja das ist ein
problem aber wenn wir nichts machen wird
es am ende noch viel teurer
naja aber auch da also worüber reden
wenn ich hier soziale politik brauchen
wir und in meine augen wird niemand in
deutschland sozusagen in einem hartz 4
system gefangen sein weil wir ein
lebensbejahender menschenfreundlichere
sagen systeme ausdenken soziale politik
ist hier aber nicht das worüber wir hier
sozusagen wir reden ja nicht von einer
frage um sozialpolitik ja nein natürlich
brauchen wir sozialpolitik und demos
menschen auffangen wir reden jetzt aber
in dieser frage um die klimakrise ja von
klimapolitik die gerecht gestaltet
werden muss und die kann sozialpolitik
und soziale maßnahmen ja nicht ersetzen
das ziel muss nur sein das klima
maßnahmen ebenso gerecht und nachhaltig
wie möglich
verteilt werden und ein mensch die sich
eben fragen so hey ich habe nicht so
viel wer bezahlt das eigentlich alles
wäre die erste antwort zu sagen gerade
jetzt bezahlt ihr weil regierungen wie
die bundesregierung über 50 milliarden
euro pro jahr an steuergelder an
subventionen für fossile energien
ausgeben wenn man das wegnehmen würde
hätte man schon ganz schön viel geld
übrig und tatsächlich die klimakrise zu
stoppen und gerechte klimawandel
voranzutreiben
gibt es da widerspruch seitens der
ökonomen werden durch höhere
energiepreise
denn darauf wird sie dann hinauslaufen
die sozial schwächeren unverhältnismäßig
stark belastet und wie könnte man dem
entgegensteuern
bevor ich dazu komme nur eine kurze
anmerkung noch wir müssen uns ehrlich
machen das ist genau der punkt aber wir
dürfen uns eben nicht nur ehrlich machen
hinsichtlich der schäden die glaube ich
immer noch unterschätzt werden da stimme
ich zu aber müssen uns auch ehrlich
machen hinsichtlich dessen was das für
den einzelnen bedeutet unter werden
viele änderungen im leben auf sie zu und
mich mal allein wenn man sich
lebensmittel anschaut ernährung das
ganze ernährungssystem das globale trägt
im durchschnitt berechnet 25 prozent zu
den globalen emissionen bei da müssen
wir unsere ernährung spiele ändern wir
müssen unser mobilitätsverhalten ändern
und das wird auch zumindest
mittelfristig oder kurzfristig etwas
kosten also zu den kosten ja die
energiepreise die fossilen energiepreise
lassen sie es mich so sagen die werden
ansteigen werden ansteigen müssen denn
wir müssen nicht nur rein in die
erneuerbaren sondern auch raus aus dem
fossilen und dann ist eben die frage wie
kann ich menschen dafür kompensieren
gerade wenn sie eben wenig haben und da
wäre eine option eben dass man
tatsächlich versucht zum beispiel
strom der immer grüner wird tatsächlich
auch günstiger zu machen da wäre eine
andere optionen dass man die einnahmen
die man generiert aus co2 preise auch
wieder an die menschen zurück verteilt
und natürlich auch die bereits
bestehenden elemente sozialer
absicherung mit einbezieht das ist ein
völlig entscheidender faktor dass wir
nicht nur immer sagen und das war lange
zeit so klimaschutz macht spaß
klimaschutz schafft jobs klimaschutz hat
eigentlich fast keine negativen
konsequenzen
das mag in 30 jahren auch so sein aber
wir müssen erstmal über quasi über diese
umstellung der systeme von fossilen auf
erneuerbare in ganz verschiedenen
bereichen in vielen bereich mit viel
investitionen da müssen wir rüber kommen
und das wird anstrengung von jedem
verlangen ja aber eben auch flankiert
von sozialen maßnahmen die dafür
ausgleich sorgen das ganze führt uns
sozusagen zur globalen rollen
verteidigung in diesem drama wenn man
das so sagen will wir wollen uns noch
mal kurz anschauen welche akteure
weltweit gesehen in sachen klimawandel
überhaupt maßgeblich sind und was diese
sich für die nächsten jahrzehnte so
vorgenommen haben
unser enormer co2 ausstoß ist maßgeblich
für die erderwärmung verantwortlich
das meiste co2 verursacht derzeit china
fast ein drittel aller jährlichen
emissionen gefolgt von den usa und an
dritter stelle europa zusammen
produzieren diese drei hauptverursacher
mehr als die hälfte aller emissionen
weltweit
in china wird ein großes umlenken noch
länger dauern die aufholjagd zur
industrie nation ist in vielen regionen
noch in vollem gange so plant china er
ab 2030 die co2 emissionen zu reduzieren
derzeit wird die hälfte der weltweit
geförderten kohle in china verbrannt und
neben dem bestehenden kohlekraftwerken
sind dort über 200 weitere geplant oder
im bau
immerhin im ausland will das land nun
keine weiteren kohlekraftwerke mehr
bauen sondern die entwicklung
klimafreundlicher technologien
unterstützen
im jahr 2060 will china dann
klimaneutral sein also nicht mehr co2
ausstoßen als in der natur gebunden
werden kann
die usa wollen für den klimaschutz 400
milliarden us dollar in den nächsten
zehn jahren in erneuerbare energien und
nachhaltige projekte investieren ende
september hat us präsident joe biden
verkündet dass im jahr 2030 die hälfte
aller neuwagen in den usa elektroautos
sein sollen klimaneutral wollen sie bis
2050 werden mit dem green deal der eu
sollen die klima- und
umweltschutzmaßnahmen der eu staaten
noch mal verstärkt werden dabei soll der
co2 ausstoß bis 2030 um mehr als die
hälfte im vergleich zu 1990 reduziert
werden das reicht aber nicht aus
kritisieren umweltschutzorganisationen
die emissionen müssten stärker gesenkt
werden bis 2050 soll auch die eu
klimaneutral sein
also das war jetzt eine ganze menge
zahlen frau neubau wird ryser uns mal
vielleicht der reihe nach auf also ein
argument das man ja von klima bremsen
oft hört ist sozusagen die nutzlosigkeit
aller bemühungen in deutschland wenn
nicht der größte co2 verursacher china
so langsam mal in die pötte kommt und
damals ja gerade gehört das wird noch
eine weile dauern was entgegnen sie
darauf also ich nehme an bloß weil china
sozusagen länger braucht heißt es nicht
dass wir in deutschland nichts machen
brauchen
man kann es sagen immer wieder argumente
wiederholen die menschen aufbringen oder
auch medien situation aufbringen die
diskus in der stagnation sehen wollen
wird die menschen immer noch einreden
wollen im jahr 20 21 für alles sagen
bpol die fluten überall sind wo wir
sehen wie stark wetterereignisse dem
mensch lebensgrundlagen zu zerstören
also wir können das alles noch weiter
wiederholen habe das argument es doch
offensichtlich klimaschutz funktioniert
nur wenn alle mitmachen wenn sich an
ihre ziele halten wir verlangt von
keinem land das sie alles machen aber
wir gemeinsam fordern auf der ganzen
welt von allen ländern sichern ihre
eigenen ziele zu halten das ist ja weder
radikalen auch wirklich zu viel verlangt
klar frau titel wo sehen sie denn
möglichkeiten vielleicht auch ja
ökonomische anreize dass man die großen
co2 sünder dieser welt also china indien
die usa aber vielleicht eben auch die eu
dass man jedoch dazu bewegt noch ein
bisschen schneller voranzukommen
wenn man schneller als 2050 wäre fürs
1,5 grad ziel natürlich sehr gut aber
2050 überhaupt schon zu erreichen
hinsichtlich klimaneutralität bin ich
bringe dich noch nicht allen die dieses
ziel bisher haben tatsächlich auch davon
überzeugt die g-20 haben sich jetzt
zudem 1,5 grad ziel bekannt sie haben
ungefähr 80 prozent der globalen
emissionen
auch da fehlt aber immer noch der
unterbau das heißt also wie will man da
hinkommen aber meines erachtens ist das
ein sehr erfolgversprechender weg dass
sich die größten emittenten also die
größten industrienationen und
schwellenländer zusammen tun und
versuchen gemeinsame maßnahmen
abzustimmen dann fällt eben auch dieses
wer bewegt sich zuerst problem weg
verstehe von neubau deutschland ist ja
klar teil der eu da gibt es diesen green
deal dann hat man jetzt gerade auch im
beitrag gesehen da wurde dann aber auch
gleichzeitig dazu gesagt dass die ziele
die die eu vorgegeben hat natürlich
schon mal ein guter schritt sind aber
auch noch nicht ausreichend sein sollen
wie ist ihre einschätzung dazu
er bestimmt also die eu setzt sich ziel
und schmückt sich mit zielen die nicht
vereinbar sind wird der pariser abkommen
das die ja auch sozusagen somit trägt
und das geht nicht auf und dann wundern
sich alle in der eu dass wir zwei so
feature sagen hey leute macht das
ehrlich so geht es nicht aber de facto
stehen wir davor dass staaten
entscheidend und auch
staatengemeinschaft mehr damit
beschäftigt sind sich ihre eigenen
bilanzen schönen zu rechnen als das zu
machen was eigentlich gebraucht wird
nämlich loszulegen und transparent
ehrlich und gerecht
das einst zu halten was man sich mit dem
pariser abkommen versprochen hat
genau ein wesentliches instrument wollen
wir gleich auch noch zu kommen zur
begrenzung des klimawandels soll
außerdem der emissionshandel seien
verbunden damit auch die bepreisung des
co2 ausstoßes auch die noch kanzlerin
angela merkel hat sich dazu geäußert
heute in glasgow und zwar ziemlich
positiv
wir werden mit staatlichen aktivitäten
alleine nicht vorankommen sondern es
geht um eine umfassende transformation
unseres lebens arbeiten zum
wirtschaftens und deshalb würde ich hier
ein klares plädoyer einlegen für die
bepreisung von kohlenstoff emissionen
von co2 emissionen mit einer solchen
bepreisung die wir einen europäischen
union schon haben die in china
eingeführt wird und die mit vielen
anderen zusammen weltweit entwickelt
werden muss können wir unsere industrie
unsere wirtschaft dazu bringen die
technologisch besten und effizientesten
wege finden um zur klimaneutralität zu
kommen
also stichworte co2 bepreisung und
emissionshandel bevor wir darüber dann
auch weiter diskutieren noch mal ein
kurzer beitrag zur erläuterung und auch
vertiefung dieses themas
ein hebel mit dem die
staatengemeinschaft den co2 ausstoß
reduzieren will ist der handel mit
emissionspapieren und das funktioniert
so
eine zentrale behörde verkauft eine
begrenzte anzahl von co2
emissionszertifikaten je nachdem wie
viele zertifikate ein unternehmen
erwirbt dafür ist die entsprechende
menge co2 ausstoßen und zahlt den preis
dafür ein vorreiter ist die eu die
bereits 2005 ihr emissionshandelssystem
für industriestrom wirtschaft und
mittlerweile auch flugverkehr eingeführt
hat die bilanz ist bisher mittelmäßig
immerhin der emissionsausstoß der
sektoren ist seit 2005 von über zwei
milliarden tonnen auf unter 1 5
milliarden tonnen jährlich gesunken die
usa haben bisher nur in einzelnen
bundesstaaten
emissionshandelssysteme china hat
kürzlich ein nationales programm
eingeführt bei diesem jahr verpflichtet
es von 2.200 chinesische unternehmen die
etwa 40 prozent der chinesischen
emissionen verursachen doch
emissionshandel ist umstritten die einen
preisen ihn als die kosteneffizienteste
klima lösung an andere kritisieren dass
das system nicht richtig greife solange
der preis pro tonne zu gering ist hat
das system nämlich kaum einen effekt
lange zeit kostete die tonne in der eu
nur etwa fünf euro ende september 2021
ist der preis auf über 60 euro gestiegen
so kann tatsächlich ein umlenken erwirkt
werden doch dafür müssen dann auch
ausreichend klimafreundliche
technologien zur verfügung stehen
ja auch ein thema das umstritten ist wie
wir gerade gehört haben frau professor
pittl frau merkel sieht in der co2
verpressung offenbar den königsweg in
sachen klimaerwärmung reduktion
wie sehen sie das
ich kann mir da zustimmen ich denke auch
dass der co2 preis sein leid instrument
der klimapolitik sein sollte das im
prinzip macht ist überall dort wo
emissionen in der produktion anfallen
oder auch im konsum setzte einen preis
darauf internalisiert quasi die kosten
die dadurch entstehen und das ist eben
nicht nur auf einzelnen dingen sondern
das spürt man überall wo auch nur zum
beispiel strom aus kohle oder erdgas
verwendet wird also insofern auf jeden
fall sehr positiv leid instrument ja
einziges instrument nein also damit
kommen wir alleine zwar schon sehr weit
aber es gibt immer noch sehr viele
probleme
infrastrukturbereich teilweise die
anwendung von ganz neuen technologien
zum beispiel wasserstoff hat mir vorhin
schon gehört grüner wasserstoff
stahlindustrie genieren das trieb da
gibt es viele dinge wo es noch
zusätzliche hürden gibt die einer
direkten umstellung dieser
industrie branchen zum beispiel
entgegenstehen und da braucht es weitere
instrumente also ein co2 preis quasi im
hintergrund der die preise richtig macht
und dann zusätzlich die instrumente gebe
es tatsächlich möglich machen auch
umzustellen
frau neubauer wie sieht denn fridays for
future den emissionshandel
wir fordern ein co2 preis in höhe von
180 euro die tonnen das ist das was das
umweltbundesamt etwa errechnet ist eine
sehr sagen einem sehr kommt eine sehr
konservative berechnung für was einen
tonnen co2 kosten könnte und man muss
sie das ja sagen bewusst machen solange
co2 nicht bepreist wird wird co2
subventionieren denn es gibt an realen
schaden der durch co2
verursacht wird und da muss man ja in
irgendeiner weise einfangen und wenn man
das nicht tut dann so könnten neben uns
halt eben und lage das sind alle aus die
am wenigsten dafür können die im zweifel
am sozial schwächsten sind und so weiter
und so fort mit welchen mechanismen an
die sind hier zwei preis 1 führt ab dass
ich jetzt sozusagen handel ist ob das
eine steuer ist das ist eine sache da es
ist überhaupt preise feature nicht die
instanz irgendwie jetzt irgendwas zu
entwickeln das ist eine frage von
ökonomen und ökonomen den menschen
sicher auskennen was aber offensichtlich
wird gerade es auch da dass es eine
großartige bereitschaft gibt es immerhin
zu führen die dann sehr bequem stellen
irgendwelche
hintertürchen haben so dass am ende doch
nicht unbequem wird und doch nicht
wirklich greift und eben das
einsparpotenzial oder ich reduziert wird
und in europa sehen wir dass eine ganz
ganz vielen verschiedenen stellen sind
weder der co2 preis ausgesetzt oder das
handelssystem und dann steht man halt
eben vor klimaziele nicht erreicht
werden kann
ja frau titel hätten sie dann noch eine
anmerkung wie man das vielleicht noch
besser machen könnte
grundsätzlich ist die eu ist dabei ist
etwas umzustellen aber muss auch sagen
nicht alles ist ausgesetzt worden bzw
das system etwas angepasst worden weil
es unbequem ist teilweise geht es eben
auch um die internationale
wettbewerbsfähigkeit der wirtschaft und
ohne die wirtschaft werden wir unsere
ziele auch nicht erreichen und da werden
wir auch keine unterstützung dafür
bekommen das heißt also wir müssen schon
versuchen dass wir das irgendwo alles
unter einen hut bringen und die eu
stellt jetzt eben um also ist zumindest
der plan nach den eu-zielen dass diese
industrie nicht mehr ihre zertifikate
also ihre berechtigung zu imitieren
umsonst bekommen sollen sondern dass
hier auch zahlen sondern dass es dann
preis quasi auf co2 preis auf importe
gibt 0 das heißt auf die art und weise
werden diese industrien dann auch direkt
in die in die pflicht genommen seien
immer ganz kurz zu den 180 euro muss man
aber auch dazu sagen es ist das lange
nicht die einzige zahl die
herumschwirren zahlen für diese kosten
von co2 emissionen also die schäden die
sie anrichten
zwischen sommer mal zehn euro und 400
euro das heißt also das ist extrem
schwer zu sagen was jetzt eine tonne co2
tatsächlich an schäden an richte das ist
von ganz vielen parametern abhängig
insofern ist jetzt die politik eher dazu
übergegangen sich zu überlegen was
brauche ich eigentlich als co2 preis um
die klimaziele zu erreichen und was mir
jetzt auch vernünftiger erscheint weil
man sich sonst ganz leicht in diesem
streit wie viel schaden richtet eine
tonne co2 an eben verliert vielleicht
noch mal eine frage auch von mir an die
ökonomen der umbau von infrastruktur und
auch energiesystem das ist ja alles
offenbar dann doch dringend erforderlich
das klingt ja eigentlich wie so ein
konjunkturprogramm für die wirtschaft
könnte ist zumindest sein wir haben
vorhin auch von volker angres die
amerikanische sozusagen sicht auf die
dinge gesehen zumindest jetzt unter dem
aktuellen präsidenten der offenbar viel
optimismus auch entwickelt und eben auch
große chancen drin sieht warum springt
die wirtschaft da nicht noch einmal
offensiver drauf
einer gewissen weise kann man natürlich
sagen das ist so eine art henne ei
problem ist also wenn infrastruktur
gebaut werden sollen ist immer die frage
wer finanziert das tankstellen systeme
sind zum beispiel in privathand
schienen sind etwas anders reguliert und
so weiter und so fort warenlager auch in
staatlicher hand es ist natürlich so
wenn die chance besteht dass der staat
das finanziert dann wird sich die
wirtschaft erst mal nicht bewegen und
darauf warten ob das nicht von
staatlicher seite geschieht das heißt
wir müssen sehr schnell sehr klare
regeln auch geschaffen werden am besten
eben regeln so dass der staat nicht
private investitionen verdrängt sondern
dass staat und private gemeinsam diese
für diese vorhaben auch vorantreiben
statt gemeinsam mit privat klingt nicht
schlecht haben sie dann frau neubauer
eigentlich nach diesem ganzen jahr
wetterextremen so der letzten zeit
insbesondere natürlich nach der
flutkatastrophe im westen deutschlands
im sommer haben sie dann noch mal
irgendwie auch eine andere wahrnehmung
des themas in ihrem umfeld dass er
wahrscheinlich sowieso schon sehr
sensibel ist aber gespürt wenn sie mit
leuten in kontakt kommen vielleicht auch
auf veranstaltung haben sie mehr zulauf
jetzt für fraser
den meisten menschen ist auch schon vor
diesem sommer also vielen vielen
menschen der schon vor diesem sommer sei
klar gewesen was los ist
interessanterweise erlebe ich eine
deutliche sensibilisierung bei den
menschen bei der bevölkerung viele viele
auch ältere generation die jetzt
feststellbar ist doch mein thema ich
dachte immer dass irgendwo ein problem
von der zukunft aber sie auch ein
problem von der gegenwart das auf jeden
fall wenn ich mir die mediale lernkurve
angucke kann ich feststellen dass ich
also meinen augen nicht wirklich was
verändert auch politisch gesehen
so stehen wir ja sozusagen nach wie vor
in einer in einem politischen geschehen
bei dem die klimakrise auch dann immer
gerne vom tisch weg gewischt wird wenn
es irgendwie ein anderes thema gibt was
man in dem augenblick interessanter
findet gerade jetzt erleben wie skurrile
situationen den koalitionsverhandlungen
dass man sich gegenseitig die
klimamaßnahmen ab verhandelt als stadt
auf zu handeln so wird es nichts also in
dem sinne gibt auch glaube ich eine
großartige
unterschiede was die bereitschaft
betrifft tatsächlich die klimakrise
nehmen wie sie ist was aber die
bevölkerung betrifft was gerade auch
junge generation betrifft bin ich
zuversichtlicher denn je denn wir sehen
dass menschen sächlich anfangen ja die
klimakrise ernst zu nehmen und auch
feststellen dass es so nicht weitergehen
kann und menschen gefragt sind regierung
unter druck zu setzen solange es nötig
ist und das machen sie und auch bei uns
haben sie dafür ja zumindest mal heute
abend eine plattform klar über die
sozusagen klimapolitik der kommenden
bundesregierung werden wir dann noch
sprechen zu gegebener zeit wenn dann die
pläne vielleicht etwas konkreter sind
heute das thema natürlich der gipfel in
glasgow frau neubauer wann wären sie
sozusagen mit diesem gipfel zufrieden
was müsste dafür reicht sein dass sie
sagen könnten okay das hat sich gelohnt
die veranstaltung
ja ich glaube die logik dieser gipfel
erlaubt nicht so recht ist das ganze ein
großer erfolg und ich habe das auch
allen beteiligten klar war es ein großer
schritt wäre ist das regierung anfang
jährlich zu werden darüber was nicht
getan wurde die versprechen nicht
eingehalten wurde auch diese art von
betrug der ja unterbrochen ausgeübt wird
an denjenigen die davon abhängen dass
regierung handle deren lebensgrundlagen
schon heute gefährdet sind die heute um
ihr zuhause bangen müssen
dass wir schon ganz ganz wichtig und wir
wissen auch klimaschutz muss natürlich
in irgendeiner form an internationalen
rahmen haben das ist die einzige
klimakonferenz in dem rahmen die wir
haben deswegen muss sie im zweifel auch
zu dem gemacht werden ja was wir
brauchen grundsätzlich aber stellen wir
fest damit diese klimakonferenz ihren
erfolg oder eine art relativer erfolg
werden kann braucht es vor allem
menschen die auf die straßen gehen
bestreiten hier am wochenende groß in
glasgow am freitag und am samstag wir
werden uns an alle menschen ihre eigene
regierung unter druck zu setzen dass
sich hier liefern wie sie es eben
versprochen haben frau professor titel
ihre antwort auf die frage wann wäre ist
ein erfolg
für mich wäre es ein erfolg werden zum
einen eben hinter den kulissen
vielleicht es weitergehen würde in
dieser vor in einem vorreiter abkommen
vorreiter club so zu sagen weil ich
glaube das bringt uns dann viele
schritte weiter gleichzeitig eben dass
die
verpflichtungen zu die bekenntnisse für
verpflichtungen auch wirklich konkrete
zusagen für zahlungen an
entwicklungsländer für unterstützung von
entwicklungsländern
vorangehen das dass da eben auch große
schritte gibt weil ich glaube viele
menschen unterschätzen auch noch dass
viele derer die heute nicht so viele mit
ihren eben die sind die in der zukunft
potenziell extrem viel emittieren können
das heißt ihnen jetzt zu helfen kann
ganz anderen pfad auflösen und dann
würde ich mich auch sehr freuen wenn
tatsächlich die verhandlungen über die
flexibilitäts mechanismen also artikel 6
tatsächlich auch abgeschlossen werden
das ist immer noch eine offene flanke
die
potenziell wenn gut ausgestaltet
wirklich viel gutes tun kann aber eben
bei schlechter ausgestaltung auch sehr
viel probleme verursachen kann also wir
sehen es ist ein wirklich sehr komplexes
vielschichtiges thema mit vielen
problemen aber auch die wir jetzt heute
abend gesehen haben doch einigen
lösungsansätzen die man dann halt eben
auch konsequent weiter verfolgen müsste
wir werden jedenfalls drauf schauen
danken ganz herzlich für das gespräch
dann uns bei dieser neubauer von
freundes verfügter und natürlich auch
bei frau professor karen pittel
klimaökonom in an münchner ifo-institut
wir danken euch ganz herzlich fürs zu
sehen und auch fürs mitmachen und
wünschen euch jetzt einen schönen abend
und sagen bis demnächst